what was it like being a roadie for
Cypress Hill and House of Pain that's
the next time you're all I'm gonna talk
about that okay
um uh I mean listen man I dropped out of
high school and went on a tour bus with
Cypress Hill and house of pain when I
was 16 years old there's I mean like are
you still friends with be real yeah of
course I text him every once in a while
we met a few times and he was like yeah
he was just cool he would text me here
yeah I mean that's that that he will
always be like my big brother I mean I
haven't talked to him in years but like
if he called me right now and said hey I
need you to do this I'd be there in two
seconds
um yeah man time I'm 16 living on a tour
bus with the biggest rap group in the
world how much pot was there on that
trip I mean we would get it sent first
of all the tour was sponsored by
Graphics remember Graphics bongs
um we would get this is before 9 11 we
would get
uh like a detergent box like a box of
Tide and they'd open the box outside put
like five ounces of weed in in a in a
you know like good weed because we'd be
in the middle of the country where there
was weed we'd have weed fedexed in
this is before obviously way before weed
was legal in in detergent boxes and so
like there was always just ounces of
nobody ever got together no because it
was you know